what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series today I am going to be
reacting to why women need to build with
men with our good friend MLD MLG was
just on the show the last two weeks so
if you like him and this clip make sure
you go and watch him on our live videos
he should be tagged in the title pull up
the clip fan of telling a woman to move
to another country and quit her job and
be fully dependent on me in a
manipulative standpoint I don't do that
I just wanted to say like I'm not trying
to be a pick me but I'm just saying that
as a woman I do want to support a man no
matter what like no matter what he
chooses to do whether it be Drop
Shipping is unsuccessful as he might be
I want to be there every step of the way
however I do think that people should
also like women themselves should try to
get jobs to help support the family help
support everyone else because you don't
want to end up like you're saying like
how Tate is just bringing women in and
then like he just dumps them and then
they have nothing to do a lot of these
men kind of want to have like a wife at
home with kids that's taking care of the
kids like full-time yeah
yeah because that's best for the kids
are you kidding
yeah I mean that's ideal no space to
have a job at the same time taking care
of the kids and taking in the man does
involve trying to find Financial stuff
for yourself trying to fund it trying to
like make you know might make a love for
it I think it should be like equal which
when it comes to work and stuff
to get caught up on
London yeah John what do we need to do
to make men great again
path to Salvation there's uh there's a
lot there endure indoor you know we've
spoken a lot this evening about this
idea of progress particularly with women
I think that the word connotes good but
I don't think it's been good I mean the
woman or I should say maybe the profile
of the person in this country who is
supposedly
um she who has benefited the most from
all the Liberation and progress that
women have made would probably be like
you know a single working woman middle
age with no children she's been
liberated from you know the constraints
of biology be that her bearing children
she's been liberated from the
constraints of a husband having to
provide for her she's a career woman
she's working she doesn't need all that
you know no need for a man or anything
like that but that also happens to be
the profile of the person in this
country who's the most likely to be
taking ssris and I think there's
something to be said about that I also
think that it's easier for women to
adapt to like Steven said more masculine
uh aspects of society because they're
naturally because of biology more
agreeable and more socialized so I think
it's easier to fit them into that
framework oh that's an interesting point
actually that women can adapt more
because we're more agreeable us we make
sense I think you can do the same with
men if you look at like the suicide
rates with men for example they're at
the highest they've ever been broadly
speaking but we don't enforce those
standards of masculinity like we would
have in the 1950s for example where
probably you had the strictest
enforcement of those ideas of like what
a man should be how he should act things
like that but men weren't killing
themselves at the race that they are now
so I think that I think that woke and
like making men feminine makes them more
depressed I think men talking about
their emotions like makes it worse for
them I don't know why I have like very
little evidence of this I just I just
like I'm like is is sitting around
crying gonna help a guy or is like going
to the gym and boxing or like working
out or like going and doing something
gonna help a dude I'm not a man you know
but this is just intuitive it's like the
more emotional we've made men the worse
they've gotten so it's like if this
stuff helped then why aren't they in a
better place now probably I think the
youngest guy here I'm 23. I remember
being in elementary school they started
bringing guidance counselors there was
all this talk about boys needing to
express their feelings more boys need to
do this you see it everywhere throughout
Society but for some reason that doesn't
quite catch on but when someone comes
along like an Andrew Tate who I agree
with pretty much everything you said
about him or even like a Jordan Peterson
who basically took fatherly advice and
and delivered it through a lens of like
Union psychology it's like this rapid
organic popularity people literally go
to like Jordan Peterson events with like
tears in their eyes thanking this guy
for telling them how to basically like
be a vaguely responsible man so I don't
think the answer is to take men and make
them more androgynous and maybe adapt to
a more androgynous frame of society I
think you need to make men be men again
and resultantly I think women need to be
like women again because I don't think
women are happy I don't think men are
happy and I don't think that they
experience depression the same way women
tend to experience depression in a much
more environmental sense meaning they
are directly affected by their
environment if they're unhappy I think
that makes them depressed men experience
depression when there's no way out of
that environment I think that we are
perfectly okay with going through
something but if we don't see a way out
because of all the progress that women
have made we've had to tilt the scale so
you guys have a greater Advantage I
think that's why so many men commit
suicide during like getting custody of
their kids because it's like they've
worked for 20 years she just took all
their money now he's on child support
that he can't afford now he doesn't know
if he's going to see the kids and if
they put an abuse allegation in there
now everyone thinks he's an abuser I
read the other day like a suicide note
from a guy that went through it and like
wrote all the reasons he was committing
suicide it was so sad like this woman
basically ruined his life a lot of times
we talk about toxic masculinity like
that's the reason why men are committing
suicide but I think toxic femininity is
way more of a problem for men committing
suicide because who who is pushing these
policies it's women who who is the one
kicking them out of the house it's women
so I think toxic femininity femininity
is responsible for way more suicides
than toxic masculinity pretty much every
aspect of life and men just don't see
that light at the end of the tunnel
that's why we just kill ourselves that's
why you know the common thing is like
well yeah yeah men are more likely to
kill themselves but women are more
likely to attempt it okay well why would
that be because women are like I'm upset
man and men are just like yeah I'm not
going to get out of this and they like
blow their head off or something and I
think that speaks to the differences in
our like natural predispositions as men
and as women and I think that we need to
acknowledge that for what it is and
restore what would be considered Base to
Base gender roles in society I think so
real just on real quick the issue that I
have with that without even getting into
the pros and cons of everything is
everything you've said will never come
to fruition this is my biggest issue
with you you have little faith
Destiny's like the king of like saying
things fast our
he's like the king of knit
pic you're never getting rid of you're
never getting rid of birth control
because women don't want to go back to
that and most men probably wouldn't even
accept hey hey hey hey all we need is
one
tyrannical ruler to get rid of birth
control you would be surprised never
taking women out of the workforce in
education right for as much as you talk
about like traditional stuff has only
benefited like the miserable middle-aged
woman the woman to your left that's
working on Tim Paul's show has largely
benefited from feminism because women
are taking serious symptoms having
political opinions even at Young ages so
I mean like I don't think that's not
true though that's again women have
always been able to have opinions like
women have written about politics for
200 plus years now it's more common now
because the values of the culture has
changed but this idea that no woman like
there are men that traveled to get
advice from women apart from that the
one argument that destroys Destiny's
whole arguments is the fact that he acts
like they weren't women
that were basically part of the
government and part of decision making
through their husbands remember you said
about the woman who made her son vote
yeah yeah so women knew how to use their
power there were a lot of men that were
sitting in this seat of power that
actually had no opinions of their own
they were literally just regurgitating
what their wife wanted to say that's
that's the reality so like he just comes
up with this crazy statements and just
things because he can speak Fast and
Loud that everybody will just believe
him it's quite weird arguing with him
because it's like you I'll go into
things thinking we're having a
conversation like I remember this
happened when I was on um sauce cast and
I was like talking about how I didn't
want trans dudes in the bathroom with me
and he was like well if conservatives
really cared about trans dudes in the
bathroom and you guys would care about
pageants and I was just like what a
pageants and I was just like well you
know I don't know much about pageants if
I'm being honest like I may tell me
what's wrong with them I don't know much
about about it and they're like well but
if you were real and it's so weird
sometimes like when I go into something
like thinking we're gonna have a
conversation and you go it like and
you're arguing with someone who's like
staring at their phone trying to get
Clips okay that's the thing every time
he argues he has like his chat in front
of him and it's like and then he just
like talks really fast and you're like
what did you just say so I don't know
he's very he's a good debater but he's
like the king of like arguing things
that don't make sense but I think it's
because he just wants to win the
argument and be right like he is that
actually looking for what's true and
what's not true is is my take on him
where like women don't have reproductive
control and women aren't allowed to go
to school and under their work I would
agree with you I think if I shared your
world view in that you seem to have a
much more positive or maybe optimistic
well and it's like if men ever he's like
there's no going back if men decided to
go back where they have absolutely could
I'm not saying they will I'm not I'm not
saying it'll happen but it's like if
metal got together and said [__] this
we're getting rid of birth control we're
taking these women out of the workforce
yeah
it's possible view of like where our
country repeal the 19th repeal the 19th
well I'm sure those of us on this side
of the table think like collapse is
imminent so I think that if and when
that happens which I don't think a
collapse would happen in the way that
people like to fantasize about what
there's like Civil War and yeah like who
would you model ourselves after like do
things to be better than us right now I
think that it's going to reach a point
where really I would say in terms of
like traditional value there's a lack of
promiscuity in Japan there's still an
issue with like older women not getting
married but the promiscuity in Japan is
not the same as it is here but it's like
you can look at different cultures and
see the good and the bad from them it's
not like you're trying to be one culture
because the the reality is that social
media is everywhere and there's a
Western influence and even more in
countries that are more traditional and
it's interesting I was watching a video
of Russian women getting interviewed in
Russia you can kind of see where like
the women the younger ones start to
change their mind and like feminism
starting to come in because the older
like the 25 and up chicks are like oh no
um we need men they're saying oh I'm
like a five maybe a six and they're like
women that would be eights and nines
here and then you see the younger women
starting to call themselves tens at like
21 22. see there's there's a shift
come on oh my God I was just gonna say I
think it'll reach a point where the
cultural entropy will reach a state
where people want to do away with these
ideas like you mentioned for example
things are going like pretty well if our
biggest problem is that like men want to
use the women's restroom or vice versa I
think that things get a lot worse than
that where those problems would be
abandoned and we return to tradition so
to speak but I do think it is a very
real problem because yeah it's one thing
if like a guy wants to use a girl's
bathroom but that is like one facet of
the whole issue which is like we are
redefining you know sex and gender and
maybe Russia is a crappy country but
their descendants are still going to be
Russians and they're still going to have
you know access to normal children
whereas in this country I might not be
you know facing a land War but I don't
know that my children are going to be
brainwashed by the popular culture to
mutilating their genitalia I certainly
don't have my Heritage anymore I
certainly am not able to well and why do
we have to live in there that's what
irritates me about Destiny with the
Trans thing
why do I have to partake in their
delusion like why do I have to change my
speech why do I have to change like why
do I have to feel comfortable with a guy
in our in our bathroom like why why do I
have to change what is a woman's space
to live in their delusion
the crazy thing is if they all believe
in all these ideologies so much why
don't they just all go together and form
their only to community but they don't
even enjoy being with each other
you know that's the thing they they beef
so much they want to be among normal
people abort and force their lifestyle
on normal people yeah yeah
history so if I don't even have my
future it's like is this really a great
country because I have reasonable access
to like food sex entertainment like no I
mean these answers I think are better I
think this country produces awesome
things like even today I think things
like this podcast or evidence of it
Russia's like Heritage is like Circle
tricking there is always a Town Square
like I mean we have media now but we
always have there was always a place
where people could debate ideas in the
US anyway I don't know like UK over
World War II where they were the
Defenders against nazisms they weren't
even aggressors against it right America
is the country that ended and the West
is largely who won against World War II
against Hitler the only reason the
Soviets killed so many people is because
the Nazis tried to invade their home
when I mean like when you look at like
in Russia no offense to Russia
economically that country is not doing
too well yeah socially that country has
a ton of problems um because the Empire
collapsed to me well yeah sure the
empire collapse and even internally like
there are a ton of issues but like sure
like is the idea that we cannot learn
anything from countries that are doing
certain things better than us the idea
isn't oh these countries are part you're
never going to find a country that's
doing things perfectly but I think you
can look at countries that still have
more intact families and ask why do they
why are their families still together
and ours are not because I'm sorry every
bad thing that happens in society is
tied back to the mother being out of the
home or the father being out of the home
you got I went to um a homeless the
homeless shelter down the street one of
the one day I was actually just
interviewing not not on camera or
anything but just the guy who like runs
it and he told me most of the men that
are Street sleepers which is like the
lowest I guess there's like classes of
homeless but they're like the lowest
homeless they they um were from like
single mother homes with multiple baby
fathers and it's like they're 80 of
prisoners are from single mother homes
uh they're more likely to run away from
school or from home they're more likely
to drop out of school they're more
likely to have mental problems I mean
daddy issues we all hear that so it's
like we see all these problems that are
happening from single mother home so why
would we not want to learn from the
countries that seem to have more intact
families now I'm not saying that they do
everything perfectly but the idea that
you can't learn from a country just
because they're doing another thing
wrong it's like I don't think it really
equates can come out and give like what
are really like even right-wing American
talking points of like you know the gays
in the west are destroying everything
and you know the jokes in the beginning
of the Ukrainian War were literally like
are your trans soldiers going to be
defeating our proud you know Russian
ethnic persons and now you've got like
Russian dudes who are like committing
suicides and ditches because now these
trans Russian soldiers are like flying
drones and dropping grenades on them
right and I mean they've got like the
archetypical like trans Ukrainian
dropping grenades on like two Russians
giving each other head and like a bunker
somewhere and it's like what's actually
happening here I I have no idea what
he's talking about I agree that they're
a problem he just sounds like he's
making [__] up and listen okay I'll say
this doesn't sound real I don't know I'm
welcoming a little bit of a snapback on
Snapchat because there are some things
in this country that are insane okay
yeah a lot of the transitions talk about
really crazy everybody thinks he's
excited for the crazy stuff nobody
thinks that because casual Visa but I'm
literally banned on Twitch permanently
that I streamed I love you guys I love
it because I was against some of the
trans athlete stuff right and I got
involved but I'm just saying that like
so I'm not saying that a snapback is
necessarily wrong but like it's it's
it's still moving in a certain direction
women are never ever ever gonna give up
everything they've got nobody wants to
give up yeah but if men take it back
where and should we can do about it
they may they may take it back they may
not take it back but the reality is they
can how much autonomy you are
presupposing that we would ask them
permission before we would say well okay
so maybe it's something
would literally like
it would be if you give you we took away
your right to an abortion and you like
cried about it outside of buildings when
the police like blocked you off and then
you basically went back to your life
surge of like legislation
that's so true I need to go to one of
these abortion things just I need to
interview these crazy ladies can you
imagine how crazy you have to be to go
to a march to be pro-abortion you know
nuts you got to be like I want to be a
[__] so bad that I'm gonna cry outside
of the Supreme Court building about
abortion like politically active because
of that it's like a politicized nagging
it's like this is
women would absolutely win because there
would be men that would side with them
in a civil war between men and women
being men are going to kill all the
women
I'm sorry I think Destiny is absolutely
deranged like he some of the things he
says I don't I don't think he actually
believes them
women will win because some men will
side with them first of all men that
would side with women there's a reason
why they will side with women like it's
like does he think it's the strongest of
men that will go inside with women
but like he just talks like he just
chats [__] no because he doesn't care
about what's true he just likes to argue
someone like Destiny would side with
women so you think if and this is yeah
I'm actually putting this out there you
think if me and Destiny should step in
the ring you think it's going to come
out it's going to be the one that's
going to work out I try you know what's
funny I tried to set up a boxing match
between him my neck I felt like that was
like a fair
yeah Nick will still punch him up
women's suffrage only happened because
there were men that also wanted it right
like the majority of class like men in
general well yeah I mean it was there
were that's true that's true there were
men that wanted it but you know I think
there's a lot more men that have dealt
with the consequences now I do think one
day men will just take the power back I
really do and he's he's he's not adding
the fact that back then women suffrages
men wanted it also because what it
sounded like a nice idea they hadn't
seen all the repercussions of it like
because one day men are gonna get tired
of being of not getting access to their
kids men are gonna get tired of getting
me too'd men are gonna be tired of being
told to be emotionally available men are
going to be get tired of these
delusional standards they're they're
gonna get tired of of building running
and maintaining a society for women that
are not grateful
so you know and I'm going to predict one
day don't know if it'll be my lifetime
but one day they'll take it back huge
talent pool it was a really interesting
I got a lot of emails about this so I
want to [__] join us too much when it
comes to like crazy like weird like
trans people and autistic people blah
blah blah there's a lot of talent there
that has migrated to places like San
Francisco we make fun of it for being
like the LGBT capital of the world
there's a lot of programmers and a lot
of talent in that pool though because
demographically they're drawn to those
types of jobs because a lot of times
like if you can code you can code I
don't give a [__] if you have a dick or
a vagina or if you use zizra pronouns
whatever if you can do the work you can
do the work so I just the thing that I
like about our Western Society to bring
it back is that like we have problems
with how much diversity we push I agree
but holy [__] we've been able to siphon
so much talent out of a lot of that
diversity even Angie Tate himself is to
some extent a product of like a really
Global I don't know what his point is
that's like the thing about him I'm like
what's here
nobody said diversity wasn't okay
again high IQ women have always had a
place in history I'm sorry this idea
that we just couldn't do anything we
couldn't read we couldn't write blah
blah blah it's just not true it's not
true
um and I I really recommend that you
read um Rachel Wilson's book occult
feminism because it goes through a lot
of the high IQ women and influential
women in history go ahead I think we
need to do some research into the causes
of the fall of
um all these civilizations that have
existed
because we might be able to oh yeah with
some interesting findings I heard um I
Rachel was telling me that that was um
in Greece that's like it was similar to
today like the women got really [__]
too much power yeah yeah or maybe maybe
it was no I think it was the Roman
Empire it wasn't Greece it's Roman
Empire I I would guess probably Sodom
and Gomorrah
from the Bible I would guess because it
kind of if you look at the story was
kind of like because of sin and all of
that and obviously sodomy comes from
that so it's kind of like yeah but I
don't know I think it'll be fun the
Aztecs all the other old
um civilizations well I didn't they
can't question like the kind the people
from Spain ruined the Aztecs yeah I
thought they destroyed them I don't know
they actually I I liked learning about
the Native Americans in school but I
don't remember too much but I also heard
that a lot of those civilizations they
were so disgusted by what they saw
because they would like sacrifice like
children and like women and men like to
the gods and the guys and they had Golds
they're just like yeah we're about to
I think that's what happened to the
Aztecs I don't know but let me know what
you guys think in the comments um do you
think men will ever take power back from
women or do you think it'll be like this
forever
um let me know in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and you know drop us super
thanks to get King a camera let's get
King King camera like the video on your
way out and we'll talk to you next time